we're going right now live to Dan
Patrick he was on air right we are on
air what is the nature of you take your
beef up with Dan Patrick a notch I fight
with you now
well the feud started with them booking
Jerry Ferrara yesterday hey hey hey Stu
gods Stu guys it's it's Jerry Ferrara
since that show he was on entourage it's
turtle really is what it is and so I was
making fun of those guys for booking
that's up Dan's fault that's Pauly's
fault he should know better and season
should really I mean you got to protect
Pauly from Pauly I'm sorry he wants to
book Gary at seton you got it Tom hey
Jerry no longer a good idea for a guest
that's what you got to do so somehow it
ratcheted up into where it looks like
we're gonna play a five-on-five
basketball game which I'm thrilled about
but I am getting all kinds of Intel you
guys are now claiming Reggie Miller to
be a debt and I am upset
yesterday guys Patrick like Reggie
Miller steroids for peds you need that
to beat us why are you yelling Dan don't
we're not taking Reggie if I take Reggie
Miller you can have John Ameche like I
don't care
Stu God's it's really it's me against
you you know lemon tart is leba tarts
above this you know that's what I love
about Dan he's smart he's above this he
doesn't lower himself I actually like
that idea better dan Patrick against you
God's one-on-one I have that idea better
because to God yeah because to God sees
our yeah he's our guidance things you
said it basketball I think the in
Patrick's gonna cry he's got some height
on me but I am down with do it we're
doing basketball back out there that
what we're doing it matters to guns it
doesn't matter
first of all I think you have to go
through Skip Bayless can you beat Skip
Bayless and then you get me there's a
bracket challenge to this okay
he's saying again you're under him he's
saying you don't deserve
to get a CD a play-in game I have to
beat no skip bayless here you go you
have to get you have to get through
Steven Naismith and then you get me
right
you know Steve Naismith again what he's
hitting you with the resume nobody's
doing I know what he's doing Patrick you
don't belong in my table how about that
with that I mean listen my table it's
much more fun over here Dan it's it's a
lot more in fact Paulie you have to get
past Paulie and then I'll play you this
will only take about 10 seconds I can
run over there right now
I agree yeah yeah you guys want to bury
Paulie every time you guys play down
yeah it's I don't play them anymore it's
not fair to them I don't want to do that
like I want to build up their morale and
and so I don't play them in basketball
that's not fair all right like if leba
[ __ ] debated with use to gods like it's
not fair for Dan to do it right no it's
not it's not but at least he actually
does do it I mean I tried to do he
includes me in conversations unlike you
and well bond Eisen and all the support
center anchors from the 90s but this was
another thing okay
hey Dan this goes back to member sports
jeopardy I was told Stu God said that he
would dominate on sports jeopardy do
God's you you did go through Paulie
where you said can you get me on sports
jeopardy okay I mean Dan I'm incapable
of shame
I absolutely went through boy I beg
Paulie to get on that show okay
back boom all right times not time
totally comfortable with that kind of
fraud but you know what maybe with a
second stugots maybe I get you on there
with other sidekicks of other radio
shows on like two other sidekicks like
Gary Dell'Abate from Howard Stern right
I get another sidekick
[Music]
I thought you guys were going to
SiriusXM is that the real Network you
guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know leverage could ask a question
right now and you and I have to answer
yes it's a it's a take off from the
magic credit content it is going to for
many future competitions and all sorts
of places golf basketball sports
jeopardy if it still exists here is the
question
tell us about the last movie you watched
about you got the first 30 seconds our
last movie I watched happened to be
tango in cash because it was on a few
days ago with my favorite believe all
time you know what it was Stallone solo
was better than Russell but I made a one
of the top ten actually Patrick the
question goes do you tell us about the
last movie you watched
I'm gonna go sits with it started you
with Adam Sandler wait Dan just ask the
question don't give an answer in the
question okay it's Romeo Must Die with
Jet Li and I watched it last night
[Music]
that's it they're good guys four more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
you